as tally said you don't need a lot of
money to get media attention but like
other things with startups when you
spend less money you'll have to work
harder yourself to make things happen a
best practice to get prepared for media
coverage is to have your own press kit
the press kit holds all of the things
you want to share with the press when
they cover your story you're going to
want to make sure your press kit has
quality assets this is simply an
information packet about your business
or your product with images screenshots
icons and other media you want to share
you should include general information
about your startup your product and your
team you should also include high
resolution files with your logo icons
screenshots of your app and other
marketing images such as people using
and enjoying your app the goal here is
to make your product shine so include
whatever does that you could also
include a picture of your team
especially if it's an a+ team you want
to brag about check out the instructor
notes for additional examples of press
kits